since he made his debut in batman issue
1 the joker has been the dark knight's
deadliest arch nemesis
as the years went on however his crimes
went beyond thematic robberies and into
brutal murders including clubbing robin
to death
with a crowbar that raises a question
that's hard to ignore
why doesn't batman just kill him i want
you to do it
it's pretty clear after all these
decades that putting a permanent end to
the joker would solve at least half of
gotham city's problems which makes it
difficult for plenty of readers to
suspend their disbelief
if you really want to know the actual
definitive answer though
we've got it you just might not like it
that's because the answer exists
entirely in our world where batman is a
fictional character
designed to appear in movies tv shows
and at least four comic books every
month
forever if batman kills the joker we
can't have any more joker stories
he is in very blunt and realistic terms
too popular to die
and he's been that way since the
beginning from the first day that jerry
robinson drew him on the page
the contrast of the smiling murderer and
the scowling spooky hero
made him batman's perfect dutch enemy
even by the dawn of the silver age when
batman became a much brighter more super
heroic character
the joker remained one of the most
prominent villains all of which is to
say that joker stories sell
they sell a lot and on top of that he's
an interesting character that creators
like to make comics about
as much as fans like to read them
unfortunately batman's real world
inability to kill the joker has to be
justified in the story
and that justification has become
exponentially more difficult over time
it's very easy to understand why batman
keeps taking the joker back to welcome
asylum when he's robbing banks and
committing gimmick crimes
even if there's an occasional murder
thrown in to keep him scary
after all no one ever asks why batman
doesn't just drag the riddler out back
and shoot him
by the time we got to the 80s though as
batman himself was redefined for a new
era
the joker was forced to become every bit
as unstoppable just on the other side
this was when he truly became batman's
opposite and if batman was going to be
the greatest hero in the world
the joker had to be the absolute worst
villain before the decade was out the
joker went from being an occasionally
murderous arch villain to the psychopath
who shot
and assaulted barbara gordon tortured
her father killed robin
and tried to murder the entire united
nations in fact all that happened in one
year by the end of the 90s the joker was
leaving a body count in the double
digits at minimum
every time he showed up and was pretty
consistently characterized as an
irredeemable monster
when jason todd the former robin that
the joker crowbarred to death
came back to life in 2005 he raised
exactly these questions
forcing batman to provide an in-story
reason for why he can't ever kill his
oldest deadliest enemy
in that story batman told jason that if
he ever killed the joker
he'd be unable to stop himself from
killing every other criminal who got in
his way
and jason like plenty of readers found
that argument to be incredibly
frustrating
can the world's greatest detective
really not tell the difference between a
guy who turned an entire city into
smiling zombies and let a death parade
through the streets from like
kite man really when you get right down
to it though
batman's attitude toward killing the
joker actually has an internal logic and
consistency
it's not actually about the joker it's
about batman himself
while casual fans might attribute
batman's famous code against killing to
the interference of the comics code
it actually dates back to 1941
pre-dating the code by 13 years
either way it became a fundamental truth
about the character
reinforcing the idea that batman has his
roots in reacting to someone taking a
life
two lives if you want to be technical
about it that's the tragedy that he
defines himself in opposition to
and the thing that he's always trying to
prevent death he's a crime fighter and
while he might fight bank robbers when
they're around
the taking of a life is the opposite of
who he is besides don't forget that
batman lives in a world where ghosts are
100
real if you thought the joker was
trouble when he was living you
absolutely do not want to know what
happens once he shows up in the
afterlife